seit jahrzehnten regler die mit putin
die vorstellung von einem russland das
wieder groß und mächtig werden soll im
heutigen russland sind dinge wie
wohlstand lebensstandard und sozialstaat
230 fast zählt was wirklich zählt ist
das image als übermächtige nation das
ergebnis dieser chauvinistischen
propaganda erleben wir gerade mit dem
schrecklichen krieg den putin in der
ukraine entfesselt hat ein ort an dem er
nichts zu gewinnen hatte außer der
bestätigung seines über jahres sorgsam
gesponnenen attraktiv wie schafft es
probieren also diese stimmung in der
russischen gesellschaft zu erzeugen was
tut der kreml um den patriotismus zu
stärken und inwieweit wird die armee zu
diesem zweck eingesetzt heute werden wir
hier auch visuell politik diese
schlüsselfragen beantworten denn die
antwort ist grundlage nährboden und
gleichzeitig ziel dieser ganzen
grausamen entwicklung und wie so oft
beginnen wir hierzu mit einem kurzen
blick in die geschichte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
habt ihr schon mal was von der
nationalen bewegung der jungen der
russischen armee angehörigen gehört nein
dann hört jetzt besser gut zu
[Musik]
jahre unmittelbar nach dem zusammenbruch
der sowjetunion war für russland sehr
kompliziert das land erlebte den totalen
absturz der installation schnell in die
höhe der rubel verlor einen großteil
seines härtesten die kronjuwelen des
wirtschafts gefüges wurden von den
musikalischen in beschlag genommen
gesprächen von großen schwierigkeiten
die auch die armee betrafen die
langjährigen defizite der russischen
streitkräfte wurden nach der
intervention in georgien im jahr 2008 in
vollem umfang deutlich
[Musik]
diese stellte dann aber einen echten
wendepunkt dar in einem kürzlich
erschienenen video über die städten
russlands dass ich euch natürlich
verlinken wärme haben wir bereits
darüber berichtet dass putin nach diesen
kriegt eine tiefgreifende militärreform
eingeleitet hat auch über diese reform
an sich haben wir schon vor über
anderthalb jahren ein ausführliches
video gedreht und unsere damaligen
einschätzungen sind und fast punktgenau
eingetroffen ihr seht also es lohnt sich
wirklich visual politik zu abonnieren
also schon frühzeitig einen umfassenden
überblick über die entwicklungen an den
wichtigsten schaltstellen der geopolitik
zu erhalten und zwar nicht erst wenn das
kind schon in den brunnen gefallen ist
bitte vergesst daher auch nicht unsere
analyse um aufklärungsarbeit über den in
der beschreibung unter diesem video
angegeben paypal spenden links
unterstützen gerade in letzter zeit war
eure hilfe maßgeblich und ich denke
zusammen könnten noch viele dinge
bewirken die für unsere gesellschaft und
kultur überlebenswichtig sein werden
wenn die als wertegemeinschaft überleben
wollen stehen jetzt viele reformen vor
uns
[Musik]
reformen über die wir in der
vergangenheit schon viel gesprochen
haben und deren gesellschaftliche und
politische umsetzung auch in zukunft
klare entschlossen und effektive leitung
und entsprechende leitlinien erfordert
manche kommentatoren werfen uns in den
letzten tagen vor wir würden nicht mehr
neutral berichten und diesen kannst du
immer wieder entgegen wir sind absolut
neutral gegenüber allen spielarten des
freiheitlich pluralistischen
demokratischen spektrums aber wir sind
nicht hier und ist auch noch allen
terror sympathisanten wichtigsten lief
lingen und feiglingen recht zu machen
und so klicks auf kosten der eigenen
werte zu generieren ich weiß dies sind
vater und zum teil plakative worte aber
ich bin der meinung auch unter diesen
leuten finden sich viele menschen deren
herz am rechten fleck schlägt das ist
links wir müssen diese menschen
mitnehmen aber nicht indem wir sie
klären lassen sondern indem wir ihn die
bittere wahrheit ins gesicht sagen nur
auf diese weise können jene lebenslügen
zerschlagen werden in die große teile
unserer gesellschaft über jahre hinweg
hinein gesteuert wurden nur durch diese
wehrhaftigkeit und entschlossenheit wird
es gelingen jene volle bandbreite des
freiheitlichen demokratischen spektrums
wieder herzustellen zu schützen und zu
bewahren und deswegen können wir nicht
neutral das heißt gleichgültig sein
gegenüber unfreiheit verbrechen unrecht
und massenmord eine gleichgültige oder
defätistisch haltung hat in der
geschichte bisher immer in die hölle
geführt also lasst uns diese reformen
mit mindestens der gleichen
entschlossenheit angehen mit der
wladimir putin seine militärreform und
seine militaristisch mit gesellschafts
und forderung angenommen ist
[Musik]
und nicht nur er seine reform erhielt
maßgebliche unterstützung in weiten
teilen der russischen gesellschaft
selbst nutzen sie von millionen stiegen
begeistert in diesem zug einer tja und
was meint ihr wer den treibstoff für
diesen zug geliefert hat der rest der
welt vor allem europa
was sie damit meinen nun der ölpreis
brach alle historisch überkochte und
füllte so die normalerweise mageren
kassen des kremls die deutsche regierung
baute zielstrebig den erdgas import aus
russland aus und so gab es für putin
keinen grund mehr zu sparen er hatte
freie hand die russischen
militärausgaben zwischen 2005 und 2008
10 zu verdoppeln und experten weisen
darauf hin dass die tatsächlichen
russischen militärausgaben viel höher
liegen als die offiziellen 61 milliarden
dollar da putin viele investitionen
geschickt hybrid und sie wie versteckt
hat aber auch die offizielle höhe
entspricht schon vier prozent des
russischen bip und ein land das schon
seit jahren so viel seiner
wirtschaftskraft in der rüstung steckt
sendet ein klares signal aus und dieses
signal kann keine botschaft des friedens
sein
[Musik]
in den letzten zehn jahren hat russland
umfangreiche investitionen neue
rüstungsprojekte getätigt so wurden in
dieser zeit die streitkräfte um mehr als
600 neue flugzeuge 840 schrauber uns
2300 drohnen aufgerüstet der kreml hat
70 prozent seiner kampfflugzeug und 27%
sondergipfels hatten fahrzeuge erneuert
die große show militärindustrie hat auch
neue technologische fähigkeiten
entwickelt so gelten russland
instrumente der elektronischen
kriegsführung mit denen fantasie
kommunikationsmittel und drohnen
abgefangen oder blockiert werden können
als denen der usa ebenbürtig aber wartet
einen moment denn die regierung putin
hat noch ein paar milliarden übrig um
ganz andere dinge zu tun
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wundere mich nur armee
so läuft beispielsweise ab 2021 ein
vierjähriges 185 millionen dollar
schweres programm mit einem einzigen
ziel die patriotische erziehung der
russen zu pusten tja so sieht's aus zu
diesen plänen gehört unter anderem dass
mindestens 600.000 kinder die reihen der
jungen armee der russischen kadetten der
jungen armee aufgenommen werden sollen
sie können ab einem alter von acht
jahren bis zur volljährigkeit beitreten
die jungen arminia könnte man als
durchaus würdigen erben der jungen
pioniere der sowjet ära ansehen
die pionierorganisation wladimir
iljitsch lenin war die
jugendorganisation das probiert union
zur verbreitung der ideologischen
grundsätze des kommunismus sie bestand
von 1922 bis 1990 und nahm jungen und
mädchen im alter zwischen 10 und 15
jahren auf die zahl der mitglieder
erreichte er in den 1970 er jahre mit 25
millionen ihren höhepunkt die
sogenannten pionier paläste dienten als
begegnungszentren in denen die jungen
leute an spielen handarbeiten und
einigen sportlichen aktivitäten
teilnahmen in den sommerferien fuhren
die jungen menschen dann in die pds
ferienlager die pioniere waren so was
die pfadfinder mit kommunistischen
abzeichen auf ihren rucksäcken und zwar
nicht ganz zufällig die
pionierorganisation wurde von den
burschen wichtig gezielt als
gegenentwurf zu den scouts den
pfadfindern gegründet deren werte
berufen nämlich auf der
bürgergesellschaft dem klassenfeind sie
wurden daher von den sowjets auch
verboten und brutal verfolgt den pseudo
kommunisten wien ist bei der ganzen
sache nämlich um viel mehr als um natur
spiele und freizeitgestaltung
im alter von 15 jahren unten die
pioniere dem komsomol beitreten einer
anderen jugendorganisationen die als tor
zur kommunistischen partei diente
verglichen mit der sv veert ära hat
potenzial aber natürlich keine
verbindungen jetzt im kommunismus
sondern ist zu einer organisation
geworden die sich hauptsächlich auf das
militär und den führerkult um plan ihn
herum konzentriert sie legt besonderen
wert auf patriotismus und den dienst in
den streitkräften mit einem von reserve
offizieren geleiteten
ausbildungsprogramm viola mia hat eine
eigene uniform die klassische karte
farbe der militärkleidung jedoch mit
einem sehr charakteristischen element
auf dem kopf ihr mitglieder tragen rote
barette mit einem abzeichen auf dem das
nun armee hallo wo hervorsticht es ist
der rote stern der russischen armee auf
dem kopf eines adlers zu den aktivitäten
dieser jugendorganisation gehören
schießübungen erste hilfe kurse und
kampfsportarten einmal im jahr
veranstaltet das russische
verteidigungsministerium den jungen
arminia kongress und dort kann man alles
finden was das russische patrioten herz
höher schlagen lässt
nationalistische kundgebung und jede
menge ausgestellter waffen
sportwettkämpfe zwischen den mitgliedern
und sogar eine wissenschafts messe um
die klügsten köpfe anzulocken und ganz
wichtig zur einstimmung spielt ein dj
neuer versionen alter patriotische
lieder unterlegt mit klassischen großen
hip hop das alles hat ein ziel jungen
russen zu zeigen dass nichts cooler ist
als eine junge kadettin arminia zu sein
und man muss sagen das alles ist
exzellent durchdacht und umgesetzt
sicherlich ist dieses programm
attraktiver als ihnen nur den
feierlichen alter junia einzutrichtern
achtung es folgt eine gekürzte fassung
dieses umbaus keine unerwünschten
russisch patriotischen anfälle oder
gehirn verrenkungen hervorzurufen und
die christliche wird darf ja auch nur in
kleinen bruchstücken wiedergegeben
werden ich schwöre nach siegen in
studium und sport zu streben um ein
patriot und ein würdiger bürger
russlands zu sein ich denke das ist noch
mal gut gegangen dieser harmlose teil
ist recht ungefährlich ihr wisst ja
safety first aber moment mal das ist
nicht die einzige strategie mit der die
russische regierung die patriotische
militärische erziehung der jugend
fördern will sie finanziert zum beispiel
auch private einrichtungen die
wettbewerber organisieren in so
unterschiedlichen disziplinen wie
geschichtskenntnisse natürlich nach
auslegung des kremls und natürlich
solche fertigkeiten die in einem
zukünftigen kriegsszenario muss nicht
sein könnten wie dem lesen von karten
oder schießübungen aber wenn es etwas
gibt bei dem sich der kreml wirklich ins
zeug gelegt hat dann ist es der bau
einer ganz besonderen einrichtung zur
förderung des patriotismus für die ganze
familie etwas das kinder und erwachsene
gleichermaßen begeistern wird wir
sprechen hier von nicht geringerer als
putins große patriotischen themenpark
und wisst ihr was lasst uns doch die
koffer packen denn wir machen jetzt
einen ausflug genau dorthin
[Musik]
park patriot disneyland auf russisch
europäische kinder träumen von einem
besuch im disneyland paris
nordamerikanische kinder von disney
world in orlando und putin hat es sich
zur aufgabe gemacht jeden in russland
dazu zu bringen den patriot park zu
besuchen natürlich wäre es schön
achterbahn in diesem park zu haben aber
nehmen wir an dass die absichten des
trainers in eine etwas andere richtung
gehen es handle sich um einen
militärischen themenpark welcher der
russischen armee gewidmet ist und sich
in der stadt problem habe findet eine
autostunde von moskau am start und ich
kann euch versichern das russische
verteidigungsministerium hat keine mühen
und kosten gescheut sage und schreibe
250 millionen euro sind für den bau
vorgesehen und alles ist bis ins
allerkleinste detail durchdacht und
geregelt
so heißt es zum beispiel dass das essen
aus der aktion besteht und man muss sich
da natürlich schon fragen ob ein solches
maß an realismus wirklich nötig ist aber
wie dem auch sei der party ist für das
vergnügen der ganzen familie gedacht und
auch hier gilt wie bei solchen
einrichtungen üblich dass vor allem bei
denen die jüngsten ein bleibender
eindruck hinterlassen werden soll der
sie idealerweise ihr leben lang trägt
eben im besten stil des punkt in
russland in diesem park können kinder
und jugendliche an aktivitäten
teilnehmen die sich ziemlich krass von
allem unterscheiden was wir von
vergnügungsparks gewohnt sind natürlich
hat es für kinder die gerne shooter
zocken trotz der unglaublich guten
grafik der spiele einen hohen reiz eine
echte waffe anzufassen oder damit sogar
zu schießen auch andere aktivitäten wird
das virtuelle fahren eines panzers die
nutzung eines 3d druckers oder die
teilnahme an der ausbildung von
kampfhunden sind nicht zu unterschätzen
darüber hinaus können die besucher im
park patriotische partei gepanzerte
transportfahrzeuge und raketenabschuss
anlagen aus allen epochen aus nächster
nähe betrachten
man bekommt eine komplette tour durch
die russische kriegsgeschichte ja ich
weiß dass ich an dieser stelle fast
schon so klinge wie in einem sponsoring
blog aber ich denke mittlerweile konnten
wir alle zweifel zerstreuen dass wir von
putin bezahlt werden und beachten dass
der park patriot auch in ordner
unternehmen ist jahr für jahr findet ihr
packt das sogenannte armee forum statt
dies ist eine internationale
veranstaltung auf der russland seine
neuesten militärische spielzeuge
ausstellt
[Musik]
es kommen natürlich auch ausländische
delegationen die von putins freundin
geschickt werden schließlich sind die
wichtigsten abnehmer russischer waffen
group bekannt indien vietnam china und
bangladesch in asien iran und irak im
nahen osten algerien und ägypten in
afrika sowie die cara und venezuela in
amerika auf jeden fall ist klar dass
diese art forum immer ein guter ort ist
um geschäfte zu machen
russland versucht mit einer rüstung show
die waffenverkäufe in den nahen osten
anzukommen wollte ein beispiel dann
schaut euch mal folgendes an saudi
arabien und die vereinigten arabischen
emirate sind stark an russische waffen
interessiert sagen wir einfach dass die
wegen des krieges im jemen einige
probleme hatten sie von anderen ländern
zu kaufen also schauten sie hier vorbei
um zu sehen was die so nach hause
mitnehmen könnten aber gut das ist eine
ganz andere geschichte denn der
eigentliche zweck dieser anlage ist es
den russen die ganze macht der
nationalen streitkräfte vorzuführen
der sieg im zweiten weltkrieg den sie
als den großen vaterländischen krieg
bezeichnen ist bei weitem das
hauptargument mit dem sie an die gefühle
der besucher appellieren vor jahren
wurde sogar eine große und nachstellung
der erstürmung des reichstags
organisiert außerdem gibt es im park ein
interaktives museum mit dem titel 1418
schritte zum sieg dies ist genau die
anzahl der tage von der kriegserklärung
hitlers an die sowjetunion bis zur
kapitulation deutschlands verstrichen
sind und ja ich weiß was er denkt aber
mark es gibt auch überall auf der welt
viele verschiedene skurrile museen und
touristenattraktionen was ist denn das
faszinierende am park patriot nun ihr
habt im grunde vollkommen recht es war
weil ich euch das wirklich spektakuläre
daran noch gar nicht gezeigt haben
es handelt sich um etwas das uns sehr
viel darüber verrät wie das heutige
russland tickt ich spreche von nichts
geringerem als der hauptkirche der
streitkräfte russlands diese kathedrale
wurde 2020 zum 75 jahrestag des
sowjetischen sieges über nazi
deutschland eingeweiht von außen sieht
fast so aus wie jede andere auch noch
zur kathedrale das sieht kg grün ist
interessanter ist ihr inneres in den
glasfenstern mussten religiöse
darstellungen das machen fürs optischen
tricks medaillen und probleme der
durchmesser der haupt kuppel beträgt
19,45 mehrzahl die ausdrücklich als
symbol für das jahr des sieges gewählt
wurde nichts nicht der kleister
parameter dieses gebäudes wurde dem
zufall überlassen alles wurde bis zum
erbrechen mit symbolik vollgepumpt
selbst die architektur erinnert an einen
raketenwerfer oder eine luftverteidigung
story aber für fans von visual politik
gibt es zwei details an dieser
kathedrale die wirklich faszinierend
sind das erste ist der fußboden und das
liegt nicht unbedingt daran dass er aus
marmor aus dem ural gefertigt worden
wäre denn das ist gar nicht der fall
nein es geht darum dass jemand ein kreml
auf die idee kam waffen und panzer die
von nazi-deutschland beschlagnahmt
worden einzuschmelzen und daraus den
boden des militärisch religiösen tipis
herzustellen so dass jeder besucher bei
jedem schritt auf den waffen des
abscheulichen faschistischen feindes
herumtrampelt das andere bemerkenswerte
element dieser kathedrale sind ihre
musik wir haben es hier mit einem jener
autor den tempel zu tun der die meisten
mosaike der welt beherbergt aber was sie
wirklich einzigartig macht sind ihre
themen neben den religiösen motiven gibt
es muss ekd ereignisse der jüngeren
russischen geschichte darstellen und was
heißt das nun heftige diskussionen
lösten mosaik aus welche wladimir putin
und josef stalin darstellen sollten
putin wurde im zusammenhang mit der
annexion erkennen und stalin in
verbindung mit der moskauer sieges
parade von 1945 vor der
basilius-kathedrale dargestellt aufgrund
wachsender kritik wurden die musiker
jedoch noch vor einweihung der kirche
entfernt
russland putin armee kirche ab scheinbar
sagen sie ist dann doch ein dass es noch
ein wenig zu anmassend ihrer putin schon
jetzt zu einem heiligen zu erklären
zumindest solange er noch präsident des
landes ist aber den entwurf dazu haben
sie jetzt somit ist schon in der
schublade natürlich darf man sich auch
die übrigen mosaike nicht entgehen
lassen sie sind den sowjetischen und
russischen armeen gewidmet es gibt ein
sehr bedeutendes mosaik auf dem zwei
engel auf eine gruppe von soldaten mit
ihren modernen lassen herabblicken eine
aufzählung erinnert an eine lange reihe
von konflikten sowjetischen intervention
zur niederschlagung der revolution in
ungarn des prager frühlings unter
invasion in afghanistan
hinzu kommen die beiden russischen
kriege in tschetschenien und andere
einsetzen jüngeren datums welche die
russische propaganda als wie der
herstellung des friedens in georgien
rückgabe der krim und kampf gegen den
internationalen terrorismus in syrien
bezeichnet und wisst ihr was auch wenn
sie in anderen angelegenheiten nicht so
vorausschauend sein mögen an dieser
stelle befinden sich die russen in ihrem
element sie haben raum gelassen für
weitere zukünftige ruhmreiche siegel der
große russische nation genau hier haben
sich schon im mai 2020 ein plätzchen für
die ukraine eingeplant auch dass sie
sich bald in das verzeichnis dieser art
von nationale erinnerung ein rein möge
was meint ihr gibt es ein besseres
symbol dafür wie militarismus und krieg
von den kreml propagandisten zu einer
wahren religion zwar dass heiligen
erhoben wird als diese riesige
militärkirche die als großes symbol mag
sie hervor stechen aber wovon wir euch
noch nicht berichtet haben ist das
vielleicht wichtigste merkmal der
militarisierung russlands überhaupt also
sperrt eure lauscher auf
die belagerte festung
russland weiß dass es nicht mehr die
sowjetunion aus der zeit des kalten
krieges ist das ist nicht mehr eine der
beiden dominierenden supermächte auf dem
planeten ist aber putin weigert sich
verbissen seine rolle als
nebendarsteller zu akzeptieren und um
sich selbst wieder als wär zu fühlen
verdammt er seine untertanen nun für
sehr sehr lange zeit zur reinen
statisten wir durften ja zeugen dessen
werden wie proteinen die ukraine monate
lang zu lande zu wasser und in der luft
umzingelte bis er schließlich angriffen
alles nur damit russland weiterhin als
großes supermacht angesehen wird
[Musik]
und bedenkt dass russland nicht alleine
sondern auch andere länder die aus der
sowjetunion vorgegangen sind von sich
abhängig gemacht hat auf diese weise
sendet die russische regierung eine sehr
klare botschaft aus jeder soll wissen
dass die russischen interessen nicht an
den grenzen russlands enden denen
dieselbe kerbe schlug ende januar
wladimir wassiljew fraktionschef von
putins partei einiges russland als in
den gremien um unterstützung für die
prorussischen separatisten im dom
bastard
wir appellieren an die führung unseres
landes die republiken lohans und jetzt
durch die lieferung von militärgütern zu
unterstützen die für die abschreckung
eine aggression notwendig sind und alle
notwendigen maßnahmen zu ergreifen um
die sicherheit ihrer bürger zu
gewährleisten
und achtung hier haben wir einen der
großen schlüsselaspekten des klinischen
marketings die russische regierung
bereitet ihre bürger seit jahren auf
einen großen kriegerischen konflikt vor
zu diesem zweck stellt sie russland als
eine belagerte festung da ihr ziel ist
es die russen glauben zu machen dass die
von feinden umzingelt sind und daher
bereit sein müssen die heimat zu
verteidigen oft werden hierzu sogar
parallel zum angriff hitler-deutschlands
auf die sowjetunion gezogen natürlich
wird dabei lieber heruntergespielt dass
die beiden mächte vorher als verbündete
polen überfallen hatten in italien gar
nicht glauben wollte dass ihn sein
schnauzbart kumpel derart hinter gehen
würde und natürlich könnten wir jetzt
bequem von unseren heimischen sofa aus
denkbar wie übertrieben ist dieser putin
doch nur aber die wahrheit ist dass
diese botschaft in der russischen
gesellschaft durchaus gut ankommt das
tut sie wirklich in einer kürzlich
durchgeführten umfrage des lewada
zentrums messer theologische forschung
wurde festgestellt was die zweitgrößte
sorge der russischen bürger ist
mehr als die hälfte der russen hat
wirklich panik vor der möglichkeit eines
weltkriegs nicht von krieg in der
ukraine sondern vor einem ausgewachsenen
weltkrieg es ist offensichtlich dass die
russische propaganda rund um die
geschichte der belagerten festung ihre
wirkung zeigt klar läuft den großen
teilen der russischen gesellschaft
einfach nur offene türen ein sie trifft
genau den richtigen nerv um diese
ewiggestrigen gruppen bei laune zu
halten und deshalb sind schlagzeilen wie
die folgende immer musik in den ohren
des kreml die nato-länder werden
aufgefordert mehr waffen an die ukraine
zu liefern der vorwand den putin
brauchtum zu tun was er will sind die
angeblichen bedrohung der sogenannten
russischen sicherheitsinteressen
dieser begriff der sicherheitsinteressen
ist natürlich ein purer optimismus
hinter dem sich hegemonialmacht und
bevormundung von nachbarn versteckt
leider hat es dieser wirklich
gefährliche äußern ist muss jedoch auch
ganz fest in die köpfe vieler menschen
außerhalb russlands gebracht aber auch
die kreml propaganda hat ihre grenzen
die meisten einfachen russen wollen
offensichtlich keinen krieg die russen
sind wie du und ich sie wollen arbeiten
sie wollen wohlstand sie wollen freiheit
aber natürlich fühlen sich die russen
auf grund des patriotismus der ihn vom
kreml seit jahrzehnten eingeimpft wird
verpflichtet ihre russischen brüder im
donbass zu verteidigen jetzt aber zu
glauben etwaige zugeständnisse des
westens zum beispiel eine garantie der
nichtaufnahme der ukraine in die nato
putin von seinem jahrelang gehegten
kriegs gegen abgebracht ist mehr als
naiv er wollte den krieg aus prinzip
oder hätte immer wieder irgendwelche
neuen vorwände dafür gefunden in allzu
heißen oder irgendwie fadenscheinig zu
rechtfertigen wir dürfen an dieser
stelle nicht vergessen dass wir es mit
einem gefährlichen psychopathen zu tun
haben der schon muss unter 99 nur
deswegen von boris jelzin zu seinem
ministerpräsidenten ernannt wurde weil
er im gegensatz zu seinem vorgänger
keine skrupel hatte die
autonomiebestrebungen der tschetschenen
brutalstmöglich niederzuschlagen er
liest kosten in den boden gleich machen
wie einst hitler warschau und diesen
mann behandelten so gut wie alle
westlichen politiker wie einen
wohlwollenden verhandlungspartner die
ganze zeit über verschlossen sie die
augen ganz fest vor der offensichtlichen
tatsache dass krieg für putin schon
immer der karrierefaktor nummer eins war
und es bis heute ist krieg hat den ema
vorangebracht in immer mehr und mehr
macht verschafft und deswegen wird er
sich immer an als instrument des eigenen
erfolgs orientieren wir dürfen daher
nicht den fehler begehen ihn als irren
abzustempeln ein psychopath ist jemand
der sich gezielt und rational verhält
mal nimmt er dafür den guten mal den
bösen mal den irren sein ziel ist die
psychische zermürbung seines gegenüber
sodass ist alles dafür tut damit er sich
die dürfen und seiner guten seite zeigt
ein wichtiges element hierbei ist seine
unberechenbarkeit mit der er sich bei
diesen jahren krieg vorteile verschaffen
möchte gegenüber den zu 100
berechenbaren und westlichen regierungen
[Musik]
zum glück randomisierte die
demokratische öffentlichkeit das spiel
ein wenig so als hätte er den
durchmarsch sicher um die westliche
öffentlichkeit in ihrer entschlossenheit
einzuschüchtern musste er eine stufe
höher schalten und ihre angst vor dem
atomkrieg führen um dann wieder
zurückzurudern die typische taktik eines
psychopathen der sein opfer durch
unberechenbarkeit vermögen will damit
das alles dafür tut um wieder den
gültigen putin zu bekommen dieselbe
taktik wendet er seit jahren schon bei
seiner eigenen bevölkerung an die
erfolgreiche annex i und ekrem im jahr
2014 gab dem russischen patriotismus
auftrieb und gleichzeitig war sich für
putin nützlich dafür vor der eigenen
bevölkerung zu verbergen dass die
russische wirtschaft nicht mehr so
schnell wächst wie zu beginn des
jahrhunderts angesichts dessen was wir
gesehen haben sollte es nicht
überraschen dass der kreml versucht
diesen schachzug in einem von inflation
und korruptionsvorwürfen geplanten
russland zu wiederholen mit anderen
worten wir können nicht ausschließen
dass der ganze konflikt ein echtes
ablenkungsmanöver ist schließlich hatte
sich ja auch gezeigt dass putin selbst
mit dem ganzen in diesem video
dargestellten aufwands und
militarisierung und aufhetzung der
russischen gesellschaft an deren grenzen
gestoßen zu sein scheint aus diesem
grunde musste er das narrativ von der
nazi durchleuchten ukraine spinnen den
krieg als spezialoperation kleinreden
und seinen soldaten den bären aufbinden
die ukraine würden sie als befreier mit
blumensträußen brot und salz empfangen
und durch diese für seine ziele
notwendige lüge verwandelte er die
ukraine zur ultimativen schlachtbank für
die zumeist jungen russischen soldaten
die frage ist nun wann stößt putins
lügens system endgültig an seine grenzen
wie zu vernehmen ist verweigerten
bereits viele weißrussische generäle und
offiziere den angriff bisher auf ihren
und klinischen nachbarn angesichts der
von verwundeten russischen soldaten
börsen und krankenhäuser in belarus die
von putin ein geplante verstärkung
seines anhängers lukaschenko wird also
ausbleiben oder wesentlich schwächer
ausfallen
[Musik]
wie dünn das eis aus lügen jedoch ist
auf dem sich gut bewegt zeigt ganz
eindeutig eine bestimmte tatsache 14
jahre lang hat er die russen auf den
großen krieg vorbereitet und wenn er in
der los tritt hat er noch nicht mal den
mumm lässt ihnen ins gesicht zu sagen er
muss seinem eigenen volk vormachen es
handle sich um einen kleinen
befreiungsschlag
andererseits dürfen wir uns keinen
illusionen hingeben was die stimmung in
der russischen mehrheitsgesellschaft
angeht der liberale teil des russischen
volkes bildet allerhöchstens 30 prozent
der bevölkerung der rest befindet sich
fest in den händen der in diesem video
geschilderten nationalistisch
militaristischen propaganda geht quasi
in einer anderen welt in der welt der
großen russischen sowjet nostalgie ihnen
wird es nichts ausmachen weder in jedem
system zu leben dass auch die
sowjetunion am leben erhielt ja wladimir
putin hat wieder den eisernen vorhang
zwischen russland und der freien welt
gesenkt sein volk zur existenz in
isolation und gewalt verdammt womöglich
für generationen jetzt wo sein
blitzkrieg plan nicht aufgehen wird
putin damit aller macht versuchen den
übergang zum totalen krieg als auch die
auswirkungen der sanktionen mit neuer
opfer propaganda zu verkaufen warum
seine chancen dafür gar nicht so
schlecht stehen und wisst ihr ja jetzt
nachdem ihr dieses video gesehen habt
[Musik]
aber jetzt seid ihr an der reihe wie
schätzt ihr die gesellschaftliche
situation in russland eine wie weit ist
die militärische indoktrination gerne
habt ihr vielleicht bekannter in
russland den über dieses thema sprechen
könnt welche parallelen seht ihr
zwischen den heutigen russland und
vorkriegs deutschland in dem sich der im
kaiserreich anerzogene preußischen
militarismus mit dem opfer legenden der
nazis der deutschlands legende und der
bolschewistischen weltverschwörung zur
unterdrückung des deutschen erfolgs
vermischt hatte mit allen folgen die wir
kennen die ma sind auf eure beiträge
schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe also dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat als
ergebnis bitte ein leichtes mit hund
folgen und vergesst bitte auch nicht an
eine kleine spende über den link in der
beschreibung unten was gut und bis bald